And we're back now this concludes the Sense Olympics.
&gt;&gt; And it's been an amazing day for sensation and perception huh Lauren.
&gt;&gt; Yes it has and I hope you've enjoyed this broadcast just as much Andy and I
have enjoyed hosting it.
&gt;&gt; And I hope you've learned something. We've covered a lot of content today but
this is the end of the road for Lauren and I and we're going to send you back
to Susan for some last words. Again I'm Andy. [MUSIC]
&gt;&gt; And I'm Lauren. Keep on sensing.
&gt;&gt; And perceiving.
&gt;&gt; Thanks, you two. I've really enjoyed being on the ground level for the Sense
Olympics. For you viewers at home, I hope you got a lot out of it. They will
recap everything in just a moment. So again, thank you for watching the Sense
Olympics. [MUSIC]